what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today um i would say it's a morning
coffee chat but i'm drinking a smoothie
today
oh my god did i not drink coffee today
it's also not morning but i should
really credit my dad to these chats
because everything that i talk about is
just stuff my dad has told me
so
my dad um
told me once never to burn a bridge
and i'm going to be honest every time
i've burned a bridge
i regretted it
because this is why he said look
there's no point in burning a bridge the
only reason you burn a bridge is if
you're angry and you're acting out of
your emotions
because
you just stop dealing with those people
there's no point in burning the bridge
you never have any idea what's going to
happen in the future
life is long you never know if you might
need them for something later
and that's not to say like he's just
trying to use people or whatever but
um he gave me a story of he had a
business partner i guess once that that
really screwed him over like he lost a
lot of money off of this business
partner
um
he said
that because he really didn't go off on
the guy
and
you know
tell him off or whatever he just stopped
dealing with him
later down the line when we were like
about to lose our house because the
housing market crashed i guess that guy
like came in
handy for him later
and he felt like a lot of the reason
that guy helps him out later was because
he didn't go off on him that
now
that's not to say there's never a reason
to burn a bridge i'm sure there is but
in general my dad's been right when i
look back at like my life and
the times like i've burned down bridges
like i never was happy i burned down
that bridge
um
like never like even even with um
x's or whatever my dad always told me
don't burn down the bridge it's not
worth it like just stop dealing with
them
and like i think of a girl in high
school oh my god this girl was so mean
to me she like bullied me in high school
and
it was so funny because i just like
never wanted to talk to her again as
soon as she graduated never wanted to
deal with her and this girl i swear to
god friends me on facebook every like
three years i don't know why
i'm like ma'am do you want me to just
i look the same
ish right
you're like 300 like i don't know what
to i can't help you man like
my point is
the more more successful you get like
people come back
and
bridges kind of start to go away because
like you're the successful one you're
the one
that ended out on top and like people
like people come back especially when
like
six like you're successful and you're
doing well
and i don't know my dad is right and
i've burned a couple bridges i've
regretted in my life so let me know in
the comments if you think there's a good
reason to burn a bridge and
let me know if you enjoyed these chats
because sometimes i wonder i'm like
should i keep doing these these are so
unprofessional and they're just random
thoughts i have but
i don't know let me know in the comments
bye love you